THIS TEAM NEEDS YOU TO SCORE A
BUCKET DOWN THE STRETCH AND YOU
ARE ABLE TO COME THROUGH.
>> THE WIZARDS CAN ESSENTIALLY
HOLD FOR THE FINAL SHOT HERE IN
O.T.
BEAL KNOWS IT.
HE'S GOT DIALLO ON HIM.
HERE COMES GAFFORD.
BEAL TO GAFFORD.
KICKS IT OUT IN THE CORNER.
KUZMA FOR THE WIN, GOT IT!
KYLE KUZMA AGAIN!
>> CLUTCH.
>> 26 FOR KYLE KUZMA.
IT'S LIKE CLEVELAND ALL OVER AND
HE'S WAVING GOOD-BYE TO THE
FOLKS IN DETROIT.
>> IT AIN'T OVER YET.
IT AIN'T OVER YET.
>> .06 REMAINING.
>> A NICE FIND BY DANIEL GAFFORD
HAVING THE PATIENCE, THE SENSE
OF URGENCY, AND A BIG CRUNCH
SITUATION, FINDING DINWIDDIE AND
DINWIDDIE BEING UNSELFISH,
FINDING KUZMA IN THE CORNER.
KUZMA SHOT IT AND I KNEW IT WAS
GOOD, I KNEW IT WAS GOOD.
>> KYLE KUZMA,